all right Annika where you from
originally where'd you grow up Menlo
Park okay and tell me what your family
hit both your parents as a kid uh yes I
did
my dad was a homicide detective and my
mom she did like computer stuff material
stuff good job oh yeah yeah very good
child dr. Madigan craziness um yeah I
know no abuse nothing from my family I
had some traumatic incidents as a
teenager but as far as growing up the
police department or my babysitter's and
I went on patrol all the time and was
lots of fun okay and uh yeah it was a
good childhood and my parents are still
together that's great mm-hm
so actually if you look at your parents
where'd you go from there um I graduated
high school two years early so I went
yeah yeah so I went right to college um
then I took a hiatus for like seven
years before graduate school you know we
do school currently I'm a law school
dropout from Stanford interesting yeah
so now you're doing I am I am now living
in the Tenderloin lots of ups and downs
brought me here what kind of stuff
happened to got you down the street here
uh well the whole getting kicked yeah I
got arrested for point zero zero four
grams over an ounce of weed when it was
still a felony and so becoming a felon
limited my chances of employment I lost
my scholarship everything so yeah I got
back on heroin which I've had a love
affair with for 23 years now so yeah
getting into that hardcore after getting
uh released from school
this is kind of what brought me on the
downward spiral here although I was a
functional addict but then I started
smoking crack and unfortunately and that
really brought me here before I was you
know at least functional you know and
been off opiates at all since I was 18
what did you draw today
fentanyl yeah yeah yeah but I don't
shoot up anymore so after like 21 years
of shooting up I haven't touched a
needle and like over a year now so I
just smoked it and yeah the efficacy is
definitely a little bit better than the
heroin you get out here on the west
coast so you're looking today we're in a
ten no I actually got lucky and the hot
team found me just sitting on Golden
Gate and now I live in a swanky hotel in
Union Square Wow yeah
thanks to them thanks to asthma I'm I'm
high-risk in the era of the corona virus
so that's temporary after six months but
it'll give me a chance to save up with
this unemployment thing so so what are
you doing for money or what were you
doing for money before you uh I was
stealing stuff and selling the
merchandise boosting yeah yeah high-end
wine usually I mean what do you think
got you from having a scholarship to
Stanford to drug-addicted homeless well
I mean I've been on era one since I was
16 so I managed to make it through all
the all the college and stuff while on
opiates methadone for a lot of you at
the high school two years early yeah is
it addict
yeah no I wasn't quite an addict when I
graduated high school I was just getting
into it right after but a series of
suicides of my best friends and high
school sweetheart kind of threw me over
the edge and just into full addiction
well yeah what does your family think of
you I'm I'm the black sheep completely
my uncle on my mom's side died of an OD
and yeah my mom just still kind of
blames me for that because during my
grandma's funeral afterwards he asked if
I could hook him up with Aaron and I did
but that's not what he died from he died
several years later but he was the only
one of my family that actually
understood me being a junkie and stuff
and their moments in your life for you
to look at your situation and say what
that helmet every day every day I mean
you're you're a great example because
it's so many of the commenters the
viewers at my channel will make comments
like like making these oh you just gotta
go to rehab and get your act together
and get a job and get back to your kids
or do that ever
here's clearly somebody's probably
brighter than everybody were just
watching this video yeah you know my dad
insists that that's all I need is a
program and it's just I know myself and
that is not what I need at all like I
can I can function with stability but
without stability and you know support
then that's where I took perhaps this
housing you now have because of chronic
virus might exactly you're gonna be
getting like over 600 a week from
unemployment so I can actually get my
[ __ ] together finally so yeah hope of
something in it oh yeah definitely
definitely I'm an artist now I've been
an artist my whole life that's always
been my like fallback thing ever many
more satisfying than loss school friend
it definitely has most definitely more
relaxing I mean I was so idealistic my
first year of school but I've become so
disillusioned drug addiction and
coronavirus might be two of the best
things that ever happened to you you
know maybe maybe you know I find my mom
always wanted me to just do my art work
instead of the law but you know I think
she's right I think she's finally right
so I finally agree with something she
sings so what what you know as somebody
who's clearly very very intelligent what
what what do you think people that are
not addicts that that watch some of my
videos and watch stories like yours what
do you think they don't understand about
addiction that it's not something that
one can just walk away from
you know it becomes a part of somebody
and I mean yeah it's a huge part of my
life I might not be a positive thing in
some people's minds but it is you know
definitely a huge part of my life and I
can't negate that at all and and those
kinds of people need to realize that it
takes more than just you know programs
and whatever else the the media and the
politicians say is the cure for
addiction it's there's a lot of aspects
to it and I don't even know them all I
don't know what would cure me but I I
function perfectly fine on minimal
amounts of opiates and I don't think I
could ever completely be off of them you
know what I really want to be I haven't
been sober sober off of everything for
over 20 years so Hideo D before uh once
years and years and years ago it was an
easy one to do that later
I have never OD no Sentinel I'm glad I
don't shoot it cuz yeah the probability
of that goes way up but that's another
thing that that my parents don't
understand about the whole heroin thing
I mean this whole fentanyl crisis is
going on and I'm you know part of that
but if I wasn't doing all the heroin my
tolerance would be so low that I would
probably be dead by now from doing the
fit and so they don't really realize
that because of having a high tolerance
of opiates I'm probably still alive
because of that they don't get it at all
they just think it's illegal so it's bad
although ironically my mom is growing
weed and smokes it constantly now that
my dad retired and it's legal but you
know hauled are you any good 38 38
mm-hmm dude kids I do not cats
so it's foreseeable that you could get
your life together or somewhat together
yeah I believe I will well this is a
phase right now of my existence and even
though you've been addicted for you for
a long time
yep yep but you do envision a day one
day when you're not addicted to not
using it all oh no no I don't think I
will ever not use opiates whether it be
methadone or fentanyl or heroin I some
other you know a future invention no but
I just I don't know myself not on
opiates what advice would you give to a
young girl who's watching this video
saying it but yeah this is something I'm
interested in um I would tell them you
know I yeah I honestly don't even know
like I'm not gonna tell anybody to not
do it but just know your limits and
don't push them like I have I mean
that's that's been my thing all the time
it's just pushing the limits and just
seeing you know how much more I could
get and yeah it doesn't always lead to
the best of places almost like the way
you're wired is the way you're wired
right telling somebody to not be wired
the way they are is exactly I have an
addictive personality if it wasn't
opiates it'd be alcohol which it was at
one point and I thankfully stopped
drinking four years ago so you know that
that was way worse than my opinion not
alcohol you don't look like an addict
well thank you I appreciate that very
much because sometimes I feel like I'm
profiled when I'm going boosting you
don't look like somebody's using drugs
on the street well thank you thank you I
I do try alright thank you so much for
talking with me absolutely good luck
with your new your new housing yes
sounds great thank you thank you
you